as missiles fell on ukrainian cities so
international condemnation rained down
on vladimir putin and the russian attack
early this morning russian troops
invaded ukraine
a free and sovereign country
and once again in the center of europe
innocent women men and children are
dying
of fear for their lives
we condemn this barbaric attack
later on thursday eu leaders will meet
to discuss developments that they'd
hoped against hope wouldn't happen and
the scale of which now none could
entirely have foreseen
from national capitals leader after
leader promised a coordinated and
unprecedented sanctions response aimed
at president putin the russian elite and
the sources and havens of russian wealth
hoping against hope again that they will
make a difference
u.s president joe biden joined a zoom
meeting of g7 leaders in a statement
earlier the u.s president said russia
alone is responsible for the death and
destruction this attack will bring and
british prime minister boris johnson set
diplomatic niceties aside describing
vladimir putin as a dictator
for all his bombs and tanks
and missiles i don't believe that the
russian dictator will ever subdue the
national feeling of the ukrainians and
their passionate belief that their
country should be free
[Applause]
but while determined efforts continue by
a number of countries to supply ukraine
with lethal and defensive weapons no one
is offering to stand shoulder to
shoulder with kiev and fight
we have made it clear that we don't have
any plans and intention of deploying
nato troops to ukraine
what we have made clear is that we have
already increased and we are increasing
the presence of nato troops in the
eastern part of the alliance on nato
territory that will not be a factor in
putin's plans for now
and neighboring countries have other
problems to consider the polish
government says nine reception points
will be opened along ukraine's border to
receive an expected wave of refugees a
country that in recent months has used
force to repel refugees from the middle
east must now brace for ukrainians
fleeing war in their thousands jonah al
jazeera
okay let's gauge the european reaction
dominick keynes in berlin the german
chancellor olav schultz was speaking a
little earlier today dom so what options
does the eu have now do we think moving
forward
well the funny thing about this is that
the eu leaders who in one sense are
decisive are
the french president the german
chancellor and they've been taking part
in a virtual summit of the g7 leaders
which has broken up in the course of the
last 45 minutes 50 minutes peter and if
you'll allow me to read the statement
that they've come up with it is pretty
strong in fairness it points it goes to
what jonah was just telling us in his
report there about sanctions the options
that are available and you won't be
surprised to hear that they condemn the
actions of russia the invasion of of
ukraine they express their unshakable
solidarity with ukraine then they go
into detail about the sorts of things
that that they consider to be important
going forward about energy stability in
the world and
the of the availability of energy
supplies being guaranteed well that
clearly is a reference to the gas
markets and the oil markets remember
that gap that's gas and oil natural gas
and oil are major cash crops as it were
revenue generators for russia and could
conceivably be targeted in sanctions and
so there is reference to that in the
statement that's coming from the g7
leaders remember that takes in the group
of seven takes in the united states the
united kingdom france germany italy
japan canada all of them expressing
solidarity and of course it includes the
eu institutions ursula van der lion and
president sean michelle as well
interestingly the g7 leaders are also
effectively
expressing their their
very serious condemnation of the role of
bjela russ in this situation remember
we've seen the pictures of russian armor
tanks and armored personnel carriers
apparently crossing the belarussian
border into ukraine on their way to kiev
was the suggestion well the g7 leaders
talking about the situation in ukraine
and belarus and condemning the role of
ukraine now this has
been dropping in the course of the last
few minutes but it's clear the g7
leaders are trying to make very
abundantly clear their position here the
japanese prime minister is saying that
he is looking at targeted economic
sanctions against russia that would be
painful and would make the russian
government realize what he considers to
be the error of their actions
this doesn't necessarily mean that this
exactly what's being put out here is
what the eu leaders will agree but it is
suggestive strongly suggestive that what
we'll hear from brussels in the hours to
come
is a variation on the theme that this
statement is putting out there and
remember it's not the only meeting
that's taking place in the course of the
next 24 hours we know that nato is going
to have a virtual summit in brussels
again tomorrow where further action may
be being discussed but pretty clear
coming from the g7 leaders there their
real
condemnation of what president putin's
troops are doing in ukraine and what
they believe the way forward should be
dom thank you very much dominic kane
they're joining us live here on the
program
uh as part of our continuing coverage
out of berlin now the uk is expected to
announce more sanctions against russia
neve barker joins us from london so as
we were discussing a little earlier neve
strong words from boris johnson talking
about vladimir putin having unleashed a
wave of violence in eastern ukraine but
the reality is the posture of nato
hasn't
changed their people are quotes ready
but it's a backup support function at
most so
beyond sanctions
where next
yeah that's a big question isn't it yeah
it is
when i was at nato headquarters last
week ahead of of course this invasion it
was nato's
um central uh identity i suppose to
reiterate time and time again that it is
a defensive organization that it poses
no threat to russia
and as such russia should freely come to
the negotiating table with the nato
alliance and sit down and hopefully come
to a nice solution to all of that that
clearly has not happened but in many
ways the uk as a nato member its hands
are tied when it comes to providing any
more military support to ukraine it's a
very very difficult difficult tight rope
to warp because
if the uk and other nato alliance
countries do too much you could be drawn
into a protracted conflict in a country
that it has no existing treaty to defend
but if it does too little then it could
be a a gift horse i suppose to to
vladimir putin and clearly he sees the
opportunity now to launch this invasion
you know just building on what we heard
there from donek and berlin i think the
question now is okay nato members are
all singing from the same hymn sheet eu
members all singing from the
same hymn sheet so is the uk as well
what about the speed in this though
because it can be very very a very very
slow process getting all eu 27 member
states to agree to anything we know that
sanctions are on the way in many
different shapes and forms but the speed
of this is going to be absolutely
crucial in sending the right signal to
the russians as quickly as possible
moscow can achieve an awful lot within
48 hours we've seen over the course of
the day already a tremendous amount has
happened if the uk and eu and nato
alliance don't act quickly
the situation will be incredibly
complicated and sanctions will be less
effective than they hope they will be uh
if they don't act immediately neve thank
you very much lee barker there uh with
uh breaking down for us what's going on
in london amongst the political leaders
there in the uk capital let's bring in
alexander bradetsky he's a senior
political analyst for finam news website
he's also a political scholar at memo
that's an international think tank he
joins us from moscow alexander brotetsky
you've been waiting there a long time
sir we do appreciate you standing by to
talk to us here on our continuing
coverage of what's going on in eastern
ukraine
question one is stage one for vladimir
putin creating some sort of
rump ukraine light
buffer zone slash protectorate going
from crimea across to lahansk up to
donetsk and encompassing the donbass
region there where all the fighting is
going on in eastern ukraine at the
moment
that's that's definitely maybe his goal
historical and maybe political as he in
his address to the nation has dismelted
the ukrainian soviet republic which was
created by the bolsheviks and vladimir
lenin
but actually i don't think so he's
politically acting for this because this
will be the actually the end of his
political regime um and he is now seen
as sort of like a dictator of sort like
saddam hussein
and even uh the attack on ukraine can be
seen as attack of the united states on
yugoslavia in 1991 regardless of mr
milos rejection that was an interference
into an independent country and putin
who mentioned the yugoslavia was
actually doing almost the same so it
looks like he is trying to use this kind
of a scenario where he would pressure
the ukrainian airport is for peace uh
maybe in a two two days or three days
because to uh have that long-standing
war with ukraine would be actually very
expensive even for the russian budget
the russian economy is not in good shape
ukrainian army was going to be fighting
back and also the parties are movement
we should not take we should take this
into account so
the things are very serious for vladimir
putin right now so and it's very
important where he would stop to
pressure ukraine to negotiate or to go
further which i don't think so would be
why do you say he's perceived as being a
dictator in russia i mean i i get it
that he's perceived as being a russian
dictator in ukraine but his popularity
figures are always very healthy in
russia
that's true but for every leader
you for example
we sometimes compare the situation to
the caribbean crisis and while the u.s
was also was also guilty
for taking part in this crisis nikita
khrushchev who acted very uh bizarrely
was actually almost two years in power
later on and then he was actually taken
away by the politburo who actually
accused him of
radical actions and he was replaced by a
much more conservative and much more
sober figure like lunate brashner so
it's very difficult i don't think the
people within the putin's inner circle
are agree with he would agree with all
these actions yes we see people noting
in advance we see people yes mr
president but it's a very difficult and
very complicated situation because let's
say in georgia in 2008 we had a
different picture georgia
did a pre-emptive attack on aposi yeah
it's breakaway republic and mr medvedev
was
who actually acted on his will also but
he did not take melissa he did not you
know hijack mr fusakas really put him in
jail that was a different time so that
happened in three days mr putin of
course is a different figure but the
burden is very heavy so even people
within my circle who supported
the independence of the republics
because yes the republics were also born
by the ukrainian side are not supporting
the war they say it should be done
diplomatically and they also blame putin
so they are
hardline putinis and there are people
who are within the food and circle but
also kind of like they have a different
opinion so things are very complicated
in the russian society it's not black
and white it's not the full support of
the president alexander
we've heard from vladimir zelinsky in
the last hour or so he was
as live as as we call it in
international television newsrooms we we
played out we went to a tape feed of him
talking to the people of ukraine about
45 minutes ago now he was saying we have
got russian pows we have done some of
their aircraft we will fight back so
he's clearly solid and sound in his
belief in his own abilities but when the
russian army is firing you know we had
at breakfast time this morning your time
those reports of russian cruise missiles
and that made me sit up and listen the
idea of russia using cruise missiles
we've heard nothing else about that in
the intervening 12 hours or so but when
mr putin is firing his bullets or his
soldiers are firing their bullets at
ukrainians is russia also however firing
bullets at the west at the outside world
firing bullets at nato firing bullets at
all those european presidents and prime
ministers who are deciding what do we do
after sanctions
well the [ __ ] that of course he's firing
bullets on the west he he hated naida
for
uh for uh for giving given this
expansion and i don't want to be a devil
advocate because i don't justify the
actions of my president but he did have
legitimate concerns of all our presence
michael gorbachev boris nikolaevich
yeltsin they all had legitimate concerns
over nato moving to russian borders and
we said no sorry we need to negotiate
and they never took us seriously that
was also a voice within the russian
community but mr putin has crossed
certain lines he crossed the line so he
crossed the line and becoming this is a
sort of a figure like saddam hussein was
for the americans right so it looks like
he is firing bullets to the united
states and of course the sanctions would
be very heavy and i don't think so the
russians want to say oh thank you very
much mr president for the milk goes you
know up or i couldn't pay my salary some
of my friends are even thinking about
immigration right now and they love
russia they're not somebody who would
say they would like to live in the west
because for the sake of it no they want
to leave because they do not agree with
the policy of the current leadership and
the young people i'm an old man so i'm
staying but younger people have
different views and they feel like for
them this is a war in the middle of
europe right which is uh we all love
russian army it's been um
we just celebrated the red army uh
anniversary and everybody are proud of
the army actions but not in this way
because yes our army is fighting against
another slavic nation so that's that's a
big reason that's alexander thank you so
much for talking to us there i suspect
from what looks like a very nice and
sounds like a very nice piano bar there
in moscow a slightly unreal moment
he's gone on a slightly unreal day of
course let's just play you some pictures
we're just receiving now coming to us
from
moscow that rather non-descript
gentleman you're looking at is one of
the key players in the room
i don't know who he is but he is a key
player because he's a very wealthy guy
because he is one
of russia's
many oligarchs vladimir putin the
russian president is in that chamber as
well
there we are of course since 2018 the
reason he's talking to them i guess is
that since 2018
several russian oligarchs and these
people are not just wealthy they are
eye-wateringly wealthy they would make
king solomon's miners blush
they are so wealthy but their companies
have been hit
by u.s sanctions it was under a thing an
umbrella piece of legislation
international legislation it was called
the countering america's adversaries
through sanctions act
because they support directly
financially politically as well
the russian government and i quote from
the act the russian government's malign
activities
around the globe all the men in that
chamber that mr putin
is addressing and talking to and i guess
bolstering and saying to them look it's
going to be okay look the economy is
going to be okay this talk of chucking
us out of the swift inter-banking system
around the world is not going to happen
because we are insulated we have ridden
the wave of sanctions now for four years
and look the economy is basically sound
because all those guys they made they
started making big amounts of money when
the soviet union felt a bit 1989 1990
when the berlin wall came down
as well when you'll remember mr
gorbachev
famously at the time said to eric
honecker the east german premier
leave the wall open and that was the
beginning
of the end of the ussr so those are the
latest pictures coming to us from moscow
uh white house correspondent kimberly
halcott tracking events for us up and
down uh the political halls of power
there at the white house so kimberly uh
what we've got an hour and a half to go
until we hear from mr biden and i guess
he's going to come out fighting with
that second more impactful
lily pad of sanctions
yeah we expect that the u.s president
when he addresses the american public
will make good on that promise that if
russia invades ignores the first rounds
of sanctions that were put in place by
the u.s and european leaders to try and
deter an invasion that the result or
consequences would be even more
punishing so we expect the u.s president
to outline what that will look like we
believe it will be some sort of a series
of sanctions designed to cut russia off
completely from the global financial
system and also end europe's dependence
permanently
on russian oil so that is what we're
watching for very carefully but also
what we're watching for carefully is
what he's going to say to the american
people because already this is an
administration that has been intimating
there will be a cost to the american
public whether it is in the form of
potential cyber attacks to american
businesses or even the rise in the price
of gasoline for their automobiles to get
to and from work so the u.s president
expect to talk about some of those costs
but why he feels it's important he
believes that this is about not just
standing up for what is right in fact
the g7 leaders as they broke up from
that meeting that virtual meeting he
participated in earlier said that
what they're doing is not only
condemning russia's actions but also
expressing solidarity for ukraine but
the u.s president is going to make the
case that this is about defending
democracy and american values do you get
the feeling uh kimberly because you and
i a year ago had lots and lots of
conversations on this program when it
was candidate biden and it was
interesting because as a democratic
presidential candidate he was kind of on
the same page as donald trump in one
regard and it was this it was i'm not
going to get sucked into big foreign
crises thousands of miles away for no
good reason and here we are he's getting
sucked into it whether he likes it or
not he's he's the guy that people go to
because they need to know what he's
thinking what he's planning
this is a problem for a president that
is already struggling in the polls he
was largely elected for reasons uh that
are domestic to get control of the
coveted pandemic that has left the
american economy sputtering and still
millions of americans struggling to find
the kind of work that they would like
and we've also seen as a result of that
the rise in inflation as americans try
to get their economy going again so his
poll numbers are already struggling and
this is not going to help them much in
fact the latest poll shows that in fact
only 26 of americans believe that the
united states should be involved in any
way in defending ukraine from a russian
invasion and so the u.s president has a
tough case to make
that not only is there the obligation
but
he may also have to explain something
that's going to get a lot more
uncomfortable he has promised a
war-weary american public that has seen
a generation of war in iraq and
afghanistan that there will be no
american boots on the ground in ukraine
here's the problem for mr biden though
if that conflict spills over into latvia
or any other neighboring nato country
there's going to be an obligation of the
united states to get involved because
that would invoke article 5 that an
attack on one is an attack on all when
it comes to the nato alliance and so
while the u.s president has made this
promise to the american public he may
now have to explain that if this goes
further than ukraine americans will be
seeing conflict again one that many
people don't want and you're right the
u.s president really shied away from on
the campaign trail kimberly thank you so
much we'll talk to you a little later mr
biden do uh to talk to the world talk to
the nation in what 55 minutes you'll
bring it to us live i'm sure thank you
very much kimberly halkett there okay it
is